The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: This is one of
my favorite lectures for 5.61.
And I hope you like it too.
OK, last time, we talked
about the hydrogen atom.
And it's the last
exactly solved problem.
And you've probably
noticed that like the way
I treated each of the
exactly solved problems,
I avoided looking at
the exact solutions.
I said we should be able to
build our own picture based
on simplifications.
And this is something
that I really
want to stress that, yes,
the exact solutions are
in textbooks.
You can program them
into your computers
and ask your computer
to calculate anything.
But sometimes you
want to know what
it is you want to
calculate and what
is the right answer or
approximately the right answer
to build insights.
Now, in 5.112 and possibly
5.111 and certainly not 3.091,
you learn something
about the periodic table.
You learn how to
make predictions
about all properties of atoms
based on some simple ideas.
What are those simple ideas?
I'm looking for
three simple ideas.
Yes.
STUDENT: Things with similar
valence configurations
behave similarly.
ROBERT FIELD: Yes, that's sort
of a second order simple idea,
that because--
I mean, it's using
the idea that if you
know that quantum numbers of
the electrons and what orbitals
are occupied, you can make
connections between atomic
and some molecular properties.
Yes.
STUDENT: If you
understand the interplay
between nuclear charge
and electric charge,
you can derive large
physical magnitudes.
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
I mean, there are things like
electronegativity, shielding.
And these are things where
if we have some intuitive
sense for how big
orbitals are and what
is the relative attractiveness
to different nuclei
of various orbitals,
you build up everything.
And most of it comes
from this lecture.
And so I'm going to talk
about the hydrogen atom
as a model for
electronic structure.
And in particular, I'm to talk
about quantum number scaling
effects.
And I'm going to be using this
semi-classical method a lot.
So we know that for
the hydrogen atom,
you can factor the wave function
into an angular part, which
is universal.
So if you understand it
once for any problem,
you understand it all the time.
And so we can just
put that aside,
because that's a done deal.
And then there's
the radial part.
And the radial part is different
for every central force
problem.
And so we want to
be able to know
what goes into the
radial part and how
to use those ideas to be
able to understand almost
any problem, even
problems where there
is more than one electron.
So I'm going to be making
use of the classical,
the semiclassical
approach, where
the classical momentum that's
conjugate to the radius,
in other words, the
radial momentum,
that we know what that is.
It's related to the
difference between the energy
and the potential energy.
And we get the momentum from
that, the classical momentum
function.
And that gives us
everything, because we
use the DeBroglie relationship
between the wavelength
and the momentum.
And I hope you
believe what I'm going
to try to do in the
time we have for this.
So there are several
important things
that I didn't get to have
time to do in lecture.
And I want to mention
them, because I probably
will write a question on
the final connected to spin
orbit and Stern-Gerlach.
So you want to understand those.
So the schedule for
today is suppose
you record a spectrum
of the hydrogen atom.
Now, that spectrum is
going to reveal something
that I regard as electronic
structure, structure
in this sense, not
of bricks and mortar
as you would talk about
the structure of building,
but what the
architect had in mind
and what the function
of the building was.
And so the structure is
kind of a mystical thing,
in which if you look
at a little bit of it,
you sort of get the
idea of all of the rest.
And so here, I'm
going to show you
how you can approach
a spectrum and to know
where you are, because
the spectrum can
be really complicated.
And there are certain
patterns that knowing
about electronic structure
enables you to say, yeah,
I've got a Google map.
I know exactly where I am.
And it's based on
some simple ideas.
So this is first
illustration of structure.
Then I'm going to go and deal
with the semiclassical methods
for calculating all electronic
properties of the hydrogen
atom.
And we get this
business of scaling
of properties with the
principal quantum number.
And that extends to Rydberg
states of everything--
atoms and molecules-- not just
the one electron spectrum.
And the Rydberg states are
special because one electron
is special.
It's outside of
all of the others.
And what we're going to
learn about next time when
we have many electrons
or more than one,
we don't have to think
about antisymmetrization.
We don't have--
we can still take
our simple minded picture
of an electron interacting
with something.
And so we can then take
what we knew from hydrogen
and describe everything about
Rydberg states of molecules.
And that's kind of exciting.
And this will be
followed by the bad news
that when you have
more than one electron,
you have to do something else.
You have to write
antisymmetric wave functions,
antisymmetric with respect to
the exchange of all electrons.
And that looks like
it's going to lead
to a tremendous headache.
But it doesn't.
But you do have to
learn a new algebra.
OK, so let's go on to this.
OK, so for the
hydrogen atom, it's
easy to solve the time
independent Schrodinger
equation.
And we get a complete set of
these Rnl radial functions,
complete set, an
infinite number.
We don't care.
You can take this-- it's
a simple one-dimensional
differential equation.
And you can solve it.
You can tell your
computer to solve it.
You don't have to have
any tricks at all.
You can just use
whatever numerical method
to find the wave functions and
calculate whatever you want.
There's no insight there.
It's the same thing as
recording a spectrum, where
you have tables
of observed lines
and maybe observed intensities.
You don't know anything.
It's a description.
And you can have a
mathematical description,
or you can have an
experimental description.
You don't know anything.
You want to have your insight
telling you what's important
and how to use what you know
about part of the spectrum
to determine other things.
For example, we have
two energy levels.
Let's say n equals
1 and n equals 2.
And there are several
things that you
would need to do in order
to know what the selection
rule for l is from this, because
the l, the orbital angular
momentum states of n
equals 2 are degenerate.
And so you could use
the Zeeman effect.
You can use radiative lifetimes.
And what you would find is we
have a p state and an s state.
And the p state
fluoresces to the s state
and the s state doesn't, unless
you apply an electric field
and it mixes with a p state
and it then fluoresces.
So there are all sorts of things
that will alert you to the fact
that there's more going on here
than just this simple level
diagram.
OK, so let's do some
elementary stuff
and then get to the Google
map for the spectrum.
We have this thing that makes
the hydrogen atom interesting.
The potential, the
radial potential
is a function of the
orbital angular momentum.
And the effective
potential is given
by h bar squared l, l plus
1, over 2 mu r squared--
and that's with a plus sign.
And we have z e squared
over 4 pi epsilon 0--
that's just stuff from the
MKS units for the Coulomb
equation-- and 1 over r.
So we have an
attractive thing that
pulls the electron
towards the nucleus.
And we have a repulsion part,
which keeps the electron away
as long as l is not equal to 0.
So this is the actual
effective potential.
This is the thing we would use
for solving the Schrodinger
equation for the
Rnl of R functions
exactly if you wanted to.
And first surprise is that the
energy levels come out to be--
for n equals 1, 2, 3, etc.
So why are the energy
levels not dependent on l?
Because it takes more ink
to write this than that.
And this can be
really important.
But there is no l dependence.
That's a surprise.
It's not true for anything
other than one-electron spectra.
But if it's true
and it has to be,
you have to have something that
says, OK, for something that's
not hydrogen. Maybe there
will be some l splitting.
Why?
Why is that?
How does this
effective potential
have an effect for something
other than hydrogen?
And we'll understand
that in a second.
OK, now there's the
question of degeneracy.
So if we pick a value of n,
we can have l equals 0, 1,
up to n minus 1.
That comes out of
the mathematics.
And I'm just assuming that
you can accept that as a fact.
We know from our study of
the rigid rotor for the Ylm
functions that the degeneracy of
the l part of the wave function
goes as 2l plus 1.
If we have an orbital
angular momentum of 0,
there's a degeneracy of 1.
Angular momentum of 1,
it has a degeneracy of 3.
We know that.
So if we do a little game.
And we look at the degeneracies
for l equals 0, 1, 2,
3, the degeneracies--
so g sub l, is 1, 3, 5, 7.
OK, now, the degeneracy for n is
going to be all of the possible
l's.
And so if we have n equals
1, we only have one l.
And so the degeneracy is 1.
If we have n equals
2, we have p and s.
And so we have 4.
And for n equals 2, we have--
I'm sorry, for n equals
1, we have only 1.
And then we have
for n equals 2, 4.
And for n equals 3, 9.
So you see 1 plus 3 is 4.
1 plus 3 plus 5 is 9.
And so the degeneracy
for n is n squared.
So as you go really high
end, you get lots of states.
And for hydrogen,
they're all degenerate.
But if they're not split,
maybe you don't care.
Of course, you do.
I better leave this down.
Now, here we are for--
suppose you take a spectrum.
And suppose it's an
emission spectrum.
You run a discharge
through gas of something
that contains hydrogen. And
you'll see a bunch of lines.
And so one of the
things you know
is that the energy
levels are separated--
they go as 1 over n squared.
And so the energy levels--
well, actually,
they're converging.
And so let's just
indicate that like this.
So suppose you ask, well,
suppose I'm at this level,
there are going to be a series
of transitions converging
to a common limit from it.
And that's a marker, a
pattern in the spectrum.
If you have essentially
an infinite number
of levels converging to a fixed
point, that's easy to see.
And so for each
level, there will
be convergence to
the same fixed point.
And so that tells you there's
a kind of pattern recognition
you would do.
And you would begin to build
up the energy level diagram
and to know which levels you're
looking at from these existence
of convergent series.
So if we're interested
in the spectrum,
we have the energy
level differences, z
squared Rydberg 1 over n squared
minus 1 over n prime squared.
That's the Rydberg equation.
And so this also
tells you something.
So suppose you're in the nth
level, well, you know this.
And now this then converges
to the ionization limit.
But there's something else.
And that is suppose we observe
two consecutive members,
n an plus 1.
You don't know what
n is, but because you
see the pattern of
this convergent series,
you can see two levels that are
obviously consecutive members
of a series.
And the question is what is n?
And, again, you can solve that
by knowing that the energy
levels go as 1 over n squared.
So the difference
between energy levels
goes as 2 z squared
r over n cubed.
This is just taking the
derivative of 1 over n squared.
We get 2 times 1 over n cubed.
And so that kind of a pattern
enables you to say, oh, yeah,
I know what n is.
So this is a kind
of a hand waving,
but this is what we
do as spectroscopists.
We're looking for a
clue as to how to begin
to put assignments on levels.
And because there is this
simple structure, which
is represented by
this Rydberg equation,
we can say where we are.
We know where we are.
We have two choices.
One is this 1 over n cubed
scaling of the energy
differences.
And the other is the
existence of a convergence
of every initial level
to a common final level.
And that's very important.
You can't assign a
spectrum unless you
know what the patterns are.
And these are two things
that come out of the fact
that there is a structure
associated with the hydrogen
atom.
OK, now, I'm going to have to
put some numbers on the board.
And it's another
illustration of structure.
Now, I'm just taking things
from a table in McQuarrie.
And this table is a table
of expectation values
of integer powers of r.
And what is this?
Every electronic property,
anything you would measure
is going to be a
function of the--
is going to involve an integral
involving a function of r.
That's what we mean by
electronic properties.
And these electronic properties
have a wonderful behavior.
So let's make a little table.
Here is the integer power.
Here is the expectation value.
And that's l.
So we start with n equals 2.
The result you get by
actually accurately evaluating
an integral--
and these are doable integrals.
They are not
numerically evaluated.
And they have a simple formula--
a0 squared n to the
fourth z squared times 1
plus 3/2 times 1 minus
l, l plus 1 minus 1/3.
These are done integrals.
I can't do them.
I wouldn't care to do them.
So that's how any
electronic property that
goes as the square of
r behaves, we get this.
This is the Bohr radius.
This is approximately
half an angstrom.
And it's the radius of
the n equals 1 Bohr orbit,
which doesn't even exist.
Right?
There are no Bohr orbits.
But we have this
Bohr model, which
explains these energy levels.
And so we use that.
And there's nothing else here.
That's the charge
on the nucleus.
Well, it's 1 for hydrogen. But
there's nothing empirical here.
And this is a sort of a
fundamental constant now,
but it's sort of empirical.
And then the next one, it has a
very interesting initial term,
a0 not squared n squared over z.
We've lost a power here.
And it again is one of these
complicated looking functions.
OK, this r to the 1,
that's how big an atom
is, the radius of the atom.
And again, we have
a closed form.
Notice that the l
is present here,
even though it's not
present in the energies.
0, that just goes
n to the 0 power.
It's just a constant
minus 1, minus 2, minus 3.
Well, minus 1,
that's what you have
for the Coulomb attraction.
And that goes as z
over a0 n squared.
And for minus 2, that goes
as z squared a0 n cubed.
And all that plus 1/2.
And for minus 3, we get z
cubed a0 cubed n cubed l,
l plus 1/2, l plus 1.
So there are all these formulas.
Well, the important thing
is the leading term.
And what you discover is that
right here something happens.
The leading term goes
as 1 over n cubed.
It doesn't matter what the
negative power of r is.
The leading term goes
as 1 over n cubed.
Why's that?
Well, that's really
important, because this 1
over n cubed behavior is telling
you something very important.
So here's the nucleus.
And here's the electron.
We can think of it
as a Bohr orbit.
If we have a
negative power of r,
then as you get farther
and farther away from r,
the property gets small.
And so what happens is for large
enough negative powers of r,
the only thing that
matters is the first lobe,
the innermost lobe
of the wave function.
And it turns out that's
the only thing that
matters for almost everything.
And so one of the things
I'm going to show you
is why does the
innermost lobe matter
and how do we use that
to understand everything,
not just about hydrogen,
but about Rydberg
states of everything.
So the scaling of
electronic properties
depending on the power of r is
another example of structure.
And if you know one thing
about the hydrogen atom,
if you make one measurement,
if you know how to use it,
you know everything.
You don't have to do
all this other stuff.
That's a really beautiful
example of structure.
And this is insight too,
because sometimes the structure
that you have for hydrogen
is only approximately
valid for other things.
And you're going to want to
know what you can use and know
how to modify it.
And I guarantee you that
nobody teaching a course
like this would ever talk
about that kind of stuff,
because, you know,
it's approximate.
It's intuitive.
And all the good stuff is
tabulated in the textbooks
and you have to memorize it.
But you don't know
how to use it.
And this is how you use it.
This is really important.
So now let me draw
some pictures.
So this is hydrogen.
This is sodium.
This is carbon monoxide.
So the electron sees a
point charge in hydrogen.
That's easy.
Now in sodium-- we
don't know yet why,
but once I've talked about
helium and many atoms,
you will know why--
there are a whole bunch of
electrons in the nucleus
or in the core of sodium.
And outside the core,
you have something
that looks hydrogenic.
But there is this core.
It's not a point.
And that leads to the appearance
of l dependence in the energy
levels, because what
you're going to find
is that l equals 0
penetrates into the core.
l equals 1 can't.
And so as you have
higher and higher l,
you're seeing less
and less of this.
And so as a result,
there is an l dependence.
But it's an s emphatically
decreasing one.
As l increases, you get
less and less sensitivity
to this inner part.
Now, CO isn't even round.
But there are nuclei.
But if you have an electron
at a high enough end,
it's outside of this core.
But again, if you pick l--
now, you can't have l for
something that's not round.
But if you're far
enough away from it,
you can pretend it's round
and use the not roundness
as a perturbation.
And so you can have
Rydberg states of CO.
And you can use the same
ideas that we developed
for the hydrogen atom to explain
the Rydberg states of CO,
anthracene--
I don't even know how to say the
names of biological molecules.
So just consider it.
If you had it in the
gas phase and you
could make a high enough
Rydberg, high enough end state,
it would look following
this kind of extrapolation
with features
common to hydrogen.
OK, so now, semiclassical--
OK, remember, you
can calculate this.
If you want to use
rigorous mathematics,
you can find an
analytic solution
for this, for hydrogen.
And that's good,
but you haven't extracted
any insight from it.
You just have it.
But the semiclassical
theory extracts insight.
So semiclassical
theory starts out
with writing the classical
equation for the momentum.
And the momentum as a
function of r, that's
a no-no from quantum mechanics.
You can't ever say we know the
momentum as a function of r.
And it's also true
in quantum mechanics,
whenever you
calculate an integral
that you need to
evaluate some property,
you're evaluating
it over all space.
But what I'm going to
show you is that many
of these integrals
accumulated a specific point
in space, which is a reminder
of the classical mechanics.
So there are things where
quantum mechanics says
you have to do something,
but there's insight
waiting to be harvested because
many of the things you have
to calculate are trivially
interpretable in terms
of semiclassical ideas.
And the semiclassical
means classical.
You can do classical mechanics.
You can calculate
the probability
of finding a particle
at a particular place.
And you can use that
information here.
And so always the relationship
between the classical momentum
function and the potential
is this equation.
p squared over 2
mu is the momentum.
And energy minus
potential is the momentum,
is the kinetic energy.
And this is how you get there.
OK, so this is the function.
And so that's one of
the important pieces.
And the other important
piece is really unexpected,
but wonderful.
And so we have this Vl of r.
If l is 0, the inner wall of
the potential is vertical.
If l is not 0, the inner
wall of the potential
isn't quite vertical,
but it might as well
be because when r gets small,
even the l l plus 1 over r
squared term gets small.
And so we get this
vertical potential.
And so what happens is we can
use the idea from DeBroglie
and say, OK, where
is the first lobe?
Where is the first node?
Well, it's half a wavelength
from the turning point.
So if we know where
the turning point is we
can draw something
that looks like that.
Now, it's a wave function, so
it's going to be oscillating.
So the important thing
is that the first lobe,
the innermost lobe, of all n
and l lines up because this
is nearly vertical and the
energy distance from here
to the bottom of the
potential at r not equal to 0
is really large.
And so if you change n or l by
1 or 2, nothing much happens.
And so if you just say,
OK, for n greater than
or equal to 6, 6, 36, the
Rydberg constant divided by 36
is not a big number,
3,000, 3,000 wave numbers.
The vertical distance is more
than 100,000 wave numbers.
So the correction
from n equals 6--
so if we have n
equals 6, n equals 7,
there isn't much change.
And so the first lobe is going
to always be at the same place.
And so one thing that
happens is they line up.
The first node for all n
and l is at the same place,
to a good approximation.
And the amplitude in this
first lobe scales as n--
so the amplitude scales
n to the minus 3/2.
I'm going to prove that.
This is where all the
insight comes from.
If you have a property, which
is essentially determined
close to the
nucleus, because you
have a negative power of the
r in the electronic property,
then the amplitude
of the wave function
will scale as n
to the minus 3/2.
And we can use this in
evaluating all integrals,
because everybody has a lobe
here, at the same point.
And the only thing that's
different from one state,
at one n l and another is
the amplitude of this lobe.
And that goes as 1
over n to 3/2 power.
OK, that's what I was afraid of.
OK.
So we're interested
in turning points.
And what's the definition
of a turning point?
Or what is the mathematical
equation that tells you
how to get the inner
nuclear dis-- the r
value for the turning point.
Yes.
STUDENT: Derivative equals 0.
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry.
STUDENT: When the derivative
of V l d r equals 0.
ROBERT FIELD: I'm
not looking for that.
I'm looking for--
so when the energy
is equal to V l of
r, plus or minus.
That's the equation
that tells you
where the turning points are.
And these are simple equations.
So it's child's play,
adult child's, to calculate
what the inner and
outer turning point is
as a function of n and l.
And so we know the
effective potential.
We pick an energy.
We know what it is because it's
the Rydberg over n squared.
So we have enough to
calculate this function, which
is a0 n squared 1 plus or
minus 1 minus l l plus 1
over n squared square root.
Now I could derive this.
You could derive this.
It's a simple closed
form equation.
And that's the foundation
of all of this.
Now, the thing that's
common for everything
is the inner turning
point, r minus,
because what we're
interested in is this.
Where is the maximum or
where is the first node
and what is the amplitude?
And so we're going to use
this equation to get all that.
All right, so the semiclassical
theory lambda n l--
that's the wavelength--
is equal to h over Pr of r.
That's DeBroglie.
But it's generalized
to a potential, which
is dependent on r, or
a momentum function,
which is dependent on r.
So now, we have to calculate
several important things
in order to build our model.
One is the classical
oscillation period.
So if I told you we have
a harmonic oscillator,
we know the energy level
spacing things are h bar omega.
And they're constant.
If we make a superposition
state of a harmonic oscillator,
there's going to be beat nodes
at integer multiples of omega.
So we can simply say, well, for
Rydberg states or for anything,
we can define the period
of oscillation as h over,
in this case, n plus 1/2
minus n Vn minus 1/2.
This is the energetic
separation between levels--
or even not levels.
We have a formula that's giving
the independence of the energy.
So this is related to
the period that we get
from the harmonic oscillator.
So this is a perfectly
legitimate way
of knowing the period.
Well, when we do that, this is
something I wrote down before,
the energy separation of
two levels differing in n
by 1 centered at n is going to
be the Rydberg divided by 2n--
well, I'll just write it down.
So we have h.
And now this hcR 2 over n cubed.
And n cubed is really important.
It came just from taking
the derivative of the 1
over n squared energy dependent.
So this is a formula that's
perfectly legitimate.
What n tells us is the period
is proportional to n cubed.
The higher you go,
the slower you go.
Second, node to
node probability.
So how long does it
take-- you have this well.
And I don't mean to draw it
like a harmonic oscillator,
but it's a well.
And so you have a node here,
and you have a node here.
And you have a particle
that's moving, classically.
How long did it take for
the center of the particle
to go from here to here?
That's an easy thing
to calculate too,
because we know classically
what the momentum is
at any point in space.
The momentum is related
to the energy difference
between here and here.
So what we're going
for is the ratio
of the time node to
node, or to next node,
to delta t turning
to turning point.
OK, well, this is 1/2
the period, right?
So we know what
1/2 the period is.
And the period goes as n cubed.
So this is the probability of
finding the particle within one
lobe of the wave function.
So we can calculate the
probability of finding
the particle within one lobe.
And it's clearly going
as 1 over n cubed.
Now, we want an amplitude.
What is the amplitude?
It's square root
of the probability.
All of a sudden, we start to see
that the amplitude in whatever
lobe we want goes as
1 over n to the 3/2.
Now, because we have this lining
up of nodes, the first node
and the first lobe
being identical,
what we have now is the
scaling of the probability
or the amplitude in the first
lobe of the wave function.
And the next thing
is again something
that's almost never
talked about in textbooks,
but it's a really fantastic
tool for understanding
stuff is suppose we want to
know the value of an integral.
So we have an integral.
And that will be, say, the
electronic wave function
in this chi
representation, as opposed
to the Rnl representation.
OK, so this is the
integral we want.
But what we really want
is a way of saying,
I can convert this
integral to a number
that I can figure out on
the back of a postage stamp.
No methods for integration.
No numerical methods.
Just insight.
So we have some
electronic property,
which comes from this integral.
But now, this is a rapidly
oscillating function.
This is another rapidly
isolating function.
And so if we were
to ask, well, how
does the integral accumulate?
In other words, let's
say we're integrating
from r minus to r prime chi
n l of r r of k chi n prime l
prime of r Vr.
So if we plotted the integral,
the value of the integral,
as it accumulates--
so we're not evaluating
the whole integral.
We're evaluating the
integral up to the r
point, the r prime point.
And what we see that there
is a stationary phase point,
where at some point in
space, the two functions
are oscillating spatially
at the same frequency.
And we already saw this for
Fermi's golden rule, right.
You have a time integral
where you have rapidly
oscillating functions.
And then when the
applied frequency
is resonant with the
difference in frequency,
we get the integral
accumulating.
So same thing.
It's easier.
And so we have this idea that
there is a stationary phase
point.
And the integral accumulates
from 0 to its final value
there.
And then there's
just little dithering
as you go out the
rest of the way.
You get in complications when
they're two stationary phase
points, because then there's
destructive or constructive
interference between them.
But it's very rare
that you have two.
You only have one.
And so if you know the
amplitude of the wave functions
at a stationary phase point,
you can calculate the integral
as a product of three things.
No integration, just one number.
And the thing that
we care about is
that almost all
electronic properties
accumulate in the innermost
lobe, because they're the same.
The wave functions are the same.
And they get more
and more different
as you go farther out.
And as a result,
since the amplitude
in this innermost lobe
goes as 1 over n to the 3/2
and you've got two functions--
you've got the nl
function and the n prime l
prime function-- you
have that the integral
is proportional to 1 over
n to the 3/2 1 over n
prime to the 3/2.
So not only do you get
expectation values,
you get off diagonal
matrix elements.
Now this is not exact.
But it tells you this is the
structure of the problem.
And if I look at
enough stuff, this
is really important to say,
how does everything scale?
And if you know
how things scale,
you know that if
you're combining
things that aren't part
of that scaling rule,
that they're just not
going to be relevant.
This is a fantastic
simplification,
because, yes, you
can do it exactly
by programming your
computer to calculate
the integral numerically.
And that's not a big deal.
But you don't know anything.
And here, you know
what to expect.
And this is a professional
spectroscopist
who survives by recognizing
patterns and using patterns.
This is beyond
numerical integrals.
This is actually understanding
the structure of the problem.
And the fact that the molecule
gives you this beautiful--
or the atom gives you
this beautiful lobe
always at the same place,
you know stationary phase.
Now, there are
other problems where
you use the stationary
phase approximation.
You always want to be trying
to use stationary phase.
For example-- and I'm
going to stop soon--
suppose you have two
potential energy curves.
Now, you don't know
what a potential energy
curve for a molecule is yet.
But you can imagine
what there is.
And so they cross.
And this is the place
where at this energy,
this curve is exactly the same
as the momentum on that curve.
And so the integral accumulates
at this curve crossing point.
Isn't that neat?
If you know what the
curve crossing point is,
you know the amplitude
of the wave function.
And you can estimate
any integral.
So this is something you
would use if you're actually
creating new knowledge again
and again, because it's deeper
than the actual
experimental observation.
It's the explanation for it.
And it's what you're
looking for and how
you use your knowledge of
what you're looking for.
That's why I like this
lecture, because it really
gives the approach that I take
to all scientific problems.
I look for an
approximate way where
I don't have to do any
complicated mathematics
or numerical integration.
I can do that just
sitting at my desk.
OK, so on Friday, we'll hear
about helium and why helium
looks horrible, but isn't.